America is racking up milestones that no
other country would want to claim the
world's richest nation is now the
world's most affected according to
official statistics the US has overtaken
everywhere else in a grim race to the
bottom
New York is slowly flattening the curve
and turning the corner but the death
rate here remains far far too high
stabilizing but it is stabilizing at an
horrific rate 783 people 777 799 these
are just incredible numbers depicting
incredible loss and pain
New York's mayor has said schools will
remain closed until September and the
lockdown remains in place for now there
are more confirmed cases of kovat 19 in
this one state than in any other country
around the world but as bad as the
figures are they're actually much better
than earlier predictions predictions
made by the White House predictions made
by academics and predictions made by
independent consultants all look like
they will now prove to have been overly
pessimistic and that is some relief
definitely a national trauma I think
we're in a global trauma about it but I
do believe that we're starting to see
glimmers of hope so that we have
starting to see a flattening of the
curve so that our death rates they're
still about flat now but the case rates
are going down
it's the Easter weekend president Trump
had hoped to reopen the country in time
for this that hasn't happened it was
never going to alistair bungle Sky News
New York